en otras noticias de la pandemia la
presidenta del consejo de ministros de
perú violeta bermúdez informó que el
primer lote de millones de vacunas jovi
19 de la farmaceútica scinopharm
llegaría al país el próximo 9 de febrero
para iniciar la vacunación al personal
de primer nivel atendiendo pacientes de
kobe pero perú también negocia la
entrega de dosis con fisher y con
johnson y johnson
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador apareció en un vídeo este
viernes en que fue difundido en redes
sociales para aclarar su estado de salud
en el quinto día de desarrollo de kobe
19 después de que se contagió con el
virus el mandatario dijo que está bien y
que debe guardar reposo contra rumores
aseguró que ya está pasando la etapa
crítica
y el presidente de colombia iván duque
anunció que la vacunación masiva contra
kobe 19 en el país se comenzará el 20 de
febrero el gobierno que había prometido
la llegada en la primera semana del mes
dijo que el retraso fue para garantizar
suficientes dosis en este sentido agregó
que se firmaron acuerdos con otras dos
farmacéuticas sinovac y modernas